une production du studio sf mais nous en
voudraient le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités ce soir là
dessus je vais attendre 2012 est
possible de terre si vous voulez nous
entendre parler davantage après la
conversation onic d'un petit mois en
jalles sûr mais pétrie en ou est-ce
qu'on enregistre encore moins de fil des
minutes de contenu exclusif
allez vous abonner à notre trio le lien
votre description très excité de l'un
des deux avait surtout sur pitchouns je
pense
le plus important c'est que vous avez
les podcasts vraiment enregistré
beaucoup y en a plein son pitch en tant
que souris à être le à l'affût des
dernières conversations qui sont passés
sur pie jones aspect c'est là que ça va
tout le monde d'avoir de l'avancé sur
tout le monde vraiment content cette
semaine de rencontres et jonathan
brouillette qui cherchant les
professeurs merci montréal
un spécialiste de la mémoire de
vieillissement et surtout la maladie
d'alzheimer donc on a parlé de ces
sujets là c'est de comprendre ces coins
de mort qu'est ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau qui tout ce qui est relatif à ce
après sur le vieillissement qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour rester les plus
allumés les plus jeunes de coeur et
d'esprit le plus longtemps possible la
réponse va vous surprendre de répondre
assurément vous serez pas vous ne
croirez pas vous avez et cliquer pour
lire l'article
pis la maladie d'alzheimer en fait
qu'est ce qui se passe aussi dans le
cerveau pourquoi ça arrive à qui ça
arrive qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
retarder ce pour prévenir ce c'était
vraiment avoir les signes avant-coureurs
les signes avant coureurs comme en
délire et sa maladie là c'était vraiment
super passionnant 1 go une sommité dans
ce domaine le plusieurs fois post
doctorat fait que juste avant de vous
laisse avec cette conversation là on va
les remercier nos sponsors fait que bon
pote qui le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par nos amis chez mindscape qui
viennent toujours de sortir de nouveaux
produits complètement une scène je vous
parlais de l'amour 4.0 fait qui a tous
les attributs de l'amour 3.0 dont poids
de proof les classes kinsale
technologique fait que vous niez pas les
bases mais il ya aussi qu'eric zogoré
notamment le fait qu'il ya un travail à
qui ça fait que si vous voulez voyager
n'est pas de danger que vote clippers se
met à vibrer dans votre sac
il ya aussi trois grandes heures de
garde en fait moi j'ai décidé d'opter
pour la le goty en fait que certains
pourraient appeler puis je laime sarah
contrôler mon goty parce que ça poussait
trop mais là avec la une des gardes pour
la longueur je capable d'aller chercher
la longueur parfaite de gotti que je
veux absolument puis ça ça vous dit
également qu'il faut l'utiliser pour
autre chose que votre badge corps c'est
vraiment un instrument idéal dom par
mois de leur nouveau transmis package
moi c'est vraiment la chose que
j'attendais depuis le début de masquer
parce que
j'adore pour mon entrejambe pour
certaines régions dans l'entrejambe le
lower qu'on connaît le réseau électrique
mais pour vraiment le une région en
particulier
j'aime soya les halles avec la bonne
vieille dame le bon vieux big bon vieux
bic et maintenant avec le sucre semoule
paquet
on a un petit trou noir aussi qui
vraiment
qui vont un petit format qui vous aident
à aller dans l'est les recoins les plus
difficiles d'accès qui s'est tellement
smoot c'est tellement c'est une région
quand même délicate on s'entend faut
faire attention puisque jamais j'ai eu
peur pour ma descendance
je n'ai jamais cessé super douce espère
facile puis après ça on a une une peau
d'une douceur inégalée pauvre et c'est
incroyable pis à un gel qui avec ceux
dont on consomme un petit peu de gel
avant comme quinconces 3 la barbe salma
et on a aussi un exfoliant tour donc
après on va mais tissot pour attendre d
un niveau de douceur de la peau inégalée
auparavant on a un code promo pour vous
autres qui le sans filtre en un mot
c'est 20 % de rabais plus la livraison
gratuite gars de chez vous là dessus que
ce soit pour vous pour l'être cher
chaque averse mindscape
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une c'est parti ça roule merci beaucoup
d'être là invités ça fait plaisir
est-ce que ce qu'en ce moment tu disais
que ça reprenait en avant on disait que
ça prenait tranquillement la recherche
est une grosse pause pendant le glas
covin aussi complètement rit-il à
montréal dans la première vague tout
arrêter là sauf certains labour qui
travaillèrent plus qu vide qui eux ont
contenu mais sinon les autres et on y
ont travaillé
nous on est arrêté jusqu'en mars à
juillet août la pression ça repris
graduellement donc haut débit moins de
monde dans la boue puis plus en plus on
pouvait encore plus de gens dans les
labos mais on continue à en croire à
suivre les distanciation est-ce que ça
rassure beaucoup compliqué ben plus
d'organisation parce que le nez fois on
peut pas être plus qu'un ou deux dans un
espace de travail donc il faut faire des
chiffes pièce à ce recueil lesdites
associations et aux labos le vous c'est
de la recherche sur la maladie d'examen
surtout chaque fois qu'il la comprendre
puis d'essayer justement delà de la
prévenir j'imagine pi2 avant con con
qu'on plonge la dame j'aimerais savoir
c'est quoi en fait on parcours
académique le pourquoi pour se rendre
jusque là sont là son point fort et donc
j j'ai fait une maîtrise à l'université
de montréal croit que tel
c'était plus une russie ans puis ensuite
tech à l'effarement mon dock chez rim
peillon que vous avez logiciel d'édition
se cacher
exactement la bourse est restée à son
laboratoire l'époque où j'étais étudiant
au doctorat donc c'était l'hôpital
douglas qui associe à l'université yale
donc ça j'ai fait je condamne s est
ensuite j'ai fait un post doc un coup ce
père vision en france à lille dans le
laboratoire de luc buée aussi un coup ce
père vision avec un labo en belgique par
de strooper qui lui donc ça aussi
c'était malade d'alzheimer neurosciences
ensuite j'ai fait un deuxième poste de
cadre aux états unis jusqu'en 2014
ce docteur lumbroso vient ensuite belge
illustre cet accord sur le même le même
sujet neuroscience maladies damanhur
sciences puis celle un projet plus
travailler sur les déficits de mémoire
qui surviennent avec la rouge un peu
moins alzheimer mais ça sera ça ce n'est
qu'elles ont scellé le principal
symptôme le plus précoce pire donc je
resté jusqu'en 2014 pas parce que j'ai
un poste à sacré coeur qui est affilié à
l'université de montréal au département
de pharmacologie physiologique par
recherche recherche c'est vraiment de la
recherche fondamentale nous on est comme
un enfant klein donc à elle pour trouver
les causes de la maladie d'alzheimer cl
brakes pose d'un cerveau c'est contre
les imitations les protéines qui sont
affectés pour trouver des médicaments
parce que pour l'instant pourquoi le
pote bon médicament qui guérit la
maladie d'alzheimer c'est parce qu'on
connaît pas encore la cause de maladie
c'est toujours été sur le sujet qui
s'intéressait depuis pratiquement le
début fnam
j'ai commencé c'était plus la mémoire ça
ça me dit a fasciné le cerveau en
premier l'organe qui se parent complexe
par intéressant intrigant puis après ça
c'était la mémoire qui m'intéressait
parce que c'est notre mémoire est
vraiment associé à qui on y est c'est le
personnel qui tourne autour de la
mémoire si dante et on le voit le sait
pas sa mère
on finit par plus trop savoir s'il ya un
grand changement pour ce qui est de la
diversion aux acteurs parce que c'était
sa mémoire flanche
donc du coup ça ça change beaucoup sa
personnalité donc ça c'est aussi
extrêmement intéressé en premier
comprendre comment ça se passe dans le
cerveau est capable d'engranger cette
information alors sur une courte puis
surtout une longue période d'état puis
après ça mais c'est venu un peu
naturellement parce que comme la maladie
d'alzheimer c'est s'est associé aux
déficits de mémoire meetic comprendre la
pathologie principal qui causent des
pertes de mémoire qui j'ai continué plus
la tuque le maintenant dans mon
laboratoire ont fait un peu des deux
équipes
pis là mais moi en fait d'un point de
vue des deux cerveaux c'est quoi qu'est
ce qui se passe dans le fond c'est ça
met une excellente passe question on
peut concevoir dans l'abstrait qu'on
sait qu'on a une mémoire
ouais sauf que dans le concret c'est
quoi comme un conte un magazine des
données comme ça puis pourquoi est ce
que le cerveau est ce qu'à fait parce
que le cerveau le seul organe n'est
capable que de mémoire ou finale surtout
le cerveau que vous mettez surtout au
cerveau dans le comment ça ça s'inscrit
dans le cerveau c'est c'est il ya
différentes régions du cerveau
chaque région du cerveau va voir sa
spécificité sa fonction donc dans le
cerveau ben il ya des régions qui sont
vraiment spécifique à la mémoire une des
régions les plus physiques on connaît le
mieux c'est l'hippocampe donc simplement
parce que le gars qui le décrit bayer il
trouvait que ça s'appelle une forme chef
de département ou dans le cerveau c'est
le pack 1 donc on a on a quatre clubs
dans quel est le lobe frontal paris et à
l'hôpital temporal donc temps précieux
sur le côté donc c'est comme à
l'intérieur du lobe temporal
salle une forme sort un peu banane suis
pas quand pourrait ressembler un hip hop
donc puis donc là il ya beaucoup de la
mémoire qui qui se forment le nom quand
on reçoit une nouvelle information
mais après ça c'est de la communication
qui se passe entre les neurones comment
lala com conçoit nouvelles informations
il ya une nouvelle protéine qui peuvent
se créer pour garder la mémoire à long
terme donc se garder un certain temps un
hippocampe furent ensuite par exemple
avec les le sommeil mais souvent on va
on le savoure rejouer ce qui se dit dans
la journée ben filière lait avec avec
joe siegler la zone c'est là que ça
consolide ce qui est exact la
consolidation de la consolidation c'est
quoi c'est le transfert d'informations
que dans l'hippocampe puis qui va aller
dans d'autres zones plus corticale puis
il faut le jouer un par boucle pour
laisser le temps aux neurones de garde
et d'assimiler l'information puis après
ça qu'on veut avoir des besoins
mais cette information là qu'ils
conservaient d'un cerveau va revenir
dans les packs ans puis on va pouvoir se
souvenir des dix mémoire des souvenirs
qu'on ait eu que les soeurs comme
éloignée dans le temps puisqu'il fait
que quand les mémoires joue dans le
cerveau ça laisse aller ça les aide à
être consultés ce que c'est le même
principe aussi même quand on est éveillé
au sens où si admettons il se passe
quelque chose où je suis mais ton de
retenir un numéro puis que si je pense
plus je les oublie c'est sûr mais si je
me le répète cinq fois je l'oublierai
plus jamais exactement exactement donc
il ya plus qu on répète pulsions on va
prendre un cours si on veut la prendre
bien il faut répéter soir trois fois
c'est bon c'est pas juste répéter comme
ça mais faut plus qu'on ait motivé
apprendre sur la matière puisque ça va
rentrer et puis parce qu'il ya un
intérêt qui se créé puis l'information
saint-régis mieux puis quand on dit
consolidation c'est quoi en fait ce
qu'il sait pas plus que de memup
d'information puisque tu ne nous rendent
le nombre de neurones et définit bouge
pas dans le temps mais il va avoir des
nouvelles connexions qui vont se faire
entre les lignes orange lisez-le c'est
donc non ils vont ils vont venir
consolider le chemin des 10 des neurones
qui ont connectés entre eux puis kiki
c'est ça qui va faire la base de notre
mémoire qui qui se consolident dans le
cerveau qui je ne vienne que quand et
plusieurs étudiants au post doc qui
travaille sur la mémoire le par coeur
c'est pour un problème pour revenir les
enfants
oui oui c'est ça il ya différentes
techniques qu'on peut avoir la pour
retenir mulet formation donc comme je
disais répéter les choses trois fois
d'en face à faire une commère et lecture
rapide puis ensuite ce ce carton un
petit peu des fois une bonne nuit de
sommeil sas à l'aide à consulter le
lendemain on rien là dessus on fait une
lecture plus attentive
puis après ça un autre jour on se le
répète puis ça allait beaucoup à retenir
l'information aux passagers d'être
unanime aux techniques existent pour ce
dernier les choses
donc ce sera un exemple de trucs donc
s'ils voulaient retenir 20 20 mo qui se
font aucun rapport entre eux
si vous faites des liens intimes ou là
si vous construisez un histoire une
lourde histoire même si c'est une
histoire complètement à kabrikha de
brand qui se tient pas debout
c'est pas grave du moment quand on fait
un lien entre team ou là il ya une
rétention d'information qui se fait
beaucoup mieux
ça s'était montré est-ce que
est-ce que sa centrale ce que moi je
peux se souvient jean lavallée qui était
un gars avec qui on faisait de la
notation qui lui il quand il y avait des
pas aussi il tapait sur une affaire qui
devenait le tisserand cas tu peux amener
à mener son objectif c'est être capable
de travailler sa mémoire puis commencer
comme cela m'est on y allait il se
faisait une liste d'épicerie pour la
l'épicerie pleuvent il commençait à se
raconter une histoire avec la liste mais
il partait quand même avec la laisse
planer laisser la liste chez eux ils
partaient avec l'histoire planer y avait
plus besoin de l'histoire puis gardé la
liste au complet puis lui voulait
l'appliquent éventuellement être capable
de faire des tours de magie fait qu à
compter des cartes et à voir les cartes
pas sans rappeler dessus mais c'est
quelque chose qui se développe ou est
tout à fait tout ce qu'ils m'ont dit
concours le des personnes le kiné morize
les choses pierrick peuvent être pire
avec ton mari chiffre à la suite de
l'autre donc il ya de faire un truc qui
existent pipe puisqu'on les pratiques
puis puisqu'on vit un bon pire plus con
c'est facile pour nous de retenir les
choses
j'avais fait le plusieurs mois des tests
pour parce que je soupçonnais peut-être
être atteints du tdah qui fait que
j'avais fait d un examen et le chili en
europe si justement le thé avec toutes
sortes de de thé est finalement le point
peut essayer de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne puis elle avait injustement
que c'était juste a bombardé plein de
mots puis après souffler que j ai répète
le plus possible comme l'avait dit le
thé quand je faisais plusieurs fois puis
à chaque fois j'en avais plus en plus
puis à 1010 est peu mais en fait j'avais
mettons 4 4 grandes catégories de
mortiers mettons avait des fluides les
meubles les moyens de transport puis un
autre affaire puis le maire a milité
n'importe comment sans mesure des
catégories puis au moment jugé katché
qui avait ses grandes catégories depuis
que je les mènerai j'organisais sont à
ma tête ma mémoire et ses enfants
d'ailleurs quelqu'un qui aime aucune
logique tu exactement exactement donc
ans on peut catégoriser
c'est aussi sa red bull
parce que c'est un peu la même dit
qu'être que l'histoire c'est quand on
lit mais ensemble puis on dit ok bon
désolé dans la catégorie sport fruits
dont tu vas attraper les 3/4 fruits qui
a été nommé puis puis souvent dans cette
et cela s'appelle l'interférence donc on
donne un mot mais là on le fait dans les
tests récemment menés pour tester voir
la mémoire de la personne puis là on va
venir avec ça un peu plus tard plomb on
attend un certain temps puis pendant ce
temps là il ya d'autres questions qui se
posent donc cette interférence le de
nouvelles informations oncle et la fois
que vous ayez au lieu-dit entendu non
mou la première fois il le rappelle et
ça complique alors que si la personne a
un mot pendant plus que c'est long
puisque c'est dur à retenir s'il ya rien
qui se disent ça va être plus facile que
s'il ya plein de choses qui se dit entre
l'élite et du et du foie toi ça me fait
penser à ma néou si j'avais jeté dans
une parce que je voulais avoir des bases
en espagnol parce que j'en avais
absolument aucune qui le ravit
on avait tout ça va demander où sont les
toilettes mais j'avais comme télécharger
c'était comme une méthode appelée
méthode piste est comme un monsieur qui
avait comme développer ces méthodes de
passage le puissant ça ressemblait
exactement ça fait c'est mettons au
début commencer par vraiment la base et
mettons c'est bonjour olam est hantée
qui le faisait répéter c'est toujours
audio puis se répéter à voix haute qui
fait que maintenant tous les deux-trois
fois pressé de passer à un autre mot à
une autre phrase est revenue au premier
plan le fait de répéter puis parce que
je m'étais verte en premier mais c'était
toujours les nations tu apprenais c'est
toujours de plus en plus espacées de ce
plan avait des nouvelles pas pressé au
pitre a mené un travail de leçons davin
qui au début tu répètes et beaucoup
beaucoup à ma nature
puis qui je trouve est ce vraiment un
bon petit rapidement avec cette méthode
le
j'ai quand même j'ai tout oublié métier
à l'époque ça marche bien à l'époque je
te mets là on parle de blocage
intermittent mais je trouvais vraiment
j'ai vraiment l'impression que comme mon
cerveau les connexions qui se faisait
c'était vraiment efficace le train de
répéter répéter répéter après ce mais
d'une des nouvelles informations
répétées road d'avant nouvelles
informations plus tard venant l'arrière
mais en espaçant de plus en plus puis
vraiment comme rapidement unis comme des
papillons je pouvais aller à la toilette
la répétition s'est pas masqué de mieux
là en terme de trucs après ça il y en a
d'autres comme matrice il ya une démo ça
peut être aussi revenir parce qu'il
commence par là même la même première
lettre
donc les mettant au titre des catégories
comme on parle et puis il ya eu après il
ya l'environnement aussi quelqu'un qui
est qui et qui est stressé et le vous
voir ça ça joue sajou sera l'hippocampe
donc c'est ça qui fait que des personnes
qui sont qui sont trop stressé
maintenant une fois ils peuvent bloquer
gelé en examen parce qu'ils ont de la
misère à retenir l'information c'est la
cepi pas assez dormir et du podcast
quand j'entre en effet se détendre et
bien dormi
le meilleur truc qui d'étudier toute la
nuit pour cet exercice la force et cela
fort qui est qu'il tipi c'est qu'on note
mettons instinctivement j'ai pas dormi
de la nuit l'examen mais l'api rejetée
je suis stressé j'ai pas dormi sa paire
chose pour la mémoire mal qu'on le sait
ouais le temps aussi dentiste une raison
aussi d'étudier pas trop loin parce que
si tu te retrouves mois al avance ça va
être loin puis il ya moins de chance que
tu t'en souviennes mais effectivement
pas dormir puis étudier toute la nuit
juste avant ton examen puis juste une
fois ça répétées de la masse de matière
que tempo
le tout les rues du creusot rue il faut
que tu viennes populaire le meilleur
truc totalement pour quelqu'un qui vous
reçoit en examen si ça prend plusieurs
jours à l'avancé par m sport chaque
adresse et ses patates
comment est ce que le cerveau fonctionne
parce que mettons les appuis des
souvenirs auxquels je je repense jamais
qui sont qui sont juste stockés dans ma
tête on dirait puisque avant en émettant
tout me va me parler de quelqu'un qui
était au secondaire et que nous autres
j'ai pas pensé depuis la dernière fois
que j'ai vu cette personne là mais je me
rappelle encore tandis que d'autre à
faire que j'oublie mettant les défauts
j'oublie le nom de quelqu'un que j'ai
rencontré la journée multi mais que ça
fait 20 ans que j'ai pas pensé à une
personne puis que l'egypte ans fait que
ça m'apparaît lucide comme si je l'avais
pas jamais oublié de ces sait comment ça
fasse écho la différence vers la mémoire
ccc c'est un genre de questions là où
c'est pourquoi j'ai pas parlé j'ai pas
vu une personne plus 20 ans puis à
marine je vois son visage pipe band qu
on se sent qu'on ait une motion rim et
il ya des souvenirs d'associations des
odeurs du moment donc ça va c'est une
des personnes qui d'une manière donnons
nous ont plus marquée que que d'autres
personnes il faut qu'elle ait une espèce
de
de d'intérêt de motivation à retenir
c'est quelqu'un que tout peu d'intérêt
que le taux plus ou alain vertus qui
quitte vraiment fait mal ou blesser ou
de savoir tenir parce qu'ils se disent
et des événements qui sont importants
pour pour toi puis ça reste longtemps
s'est dit plus que c'est la personne est
associée à d'autres souvenirs que c'est
facile ce qui se forme comme réseau
comme la porte exactement un network
autour de cette personne-là puis plus
qu'ils s'allient puisqu'il y est présent
que tout ça a été difficile d'effacer
cette morne
ça c'est vraiment intéressant à fait
calmes et on sait on peut penser qu'il
campe vraiment quelqu'un du secondaire
c'est qu'il ya tout un network de
souvenirs liés à mon second aura des
amis que j'avais qui sont encore dans ma
vie qui cette personne-là fait partie
d'une étoile qui est plus solide que
quelqu'un y aurait rencontré dans un
centre d'achats hors de compte d'un
contexte qui est en ma mémoire exact
pide fois sous ça vous est déjà arrivé
une personne que tu connais très bien
mais t'es pas capable d'arts plastiques
développer juste parce que et dans un
contexte colonne modes différents dont
il est connu
à l'école et aux primaires pilote tout
la voix mais c'est la piscine qui tue
tête avec ta famille qui étaient en
vacances a indiqué de choses mais le lay
il ment comme le contexte de cette
personne là pis là ça devient plus
difficile que des fois ça c'est bien
beau mais là un peu plus tard dans la
journée sa clique personne n'est certain
c'est que la personne ne pas reconnaître
ces informations l'information qu'on
peut penser qui a été effacé notre
cerveau est le comme dormantes
en attendant qu'ils et kaman et ont
roulé terroir puis c'est fou quand même
le pendant des années et jamais des
choses qu'on peut pas penser mais
finalement ça reste enregistré le tous
ensemble mais peu de tout mais beaucoup
de choses donc des fois il ya des stress
post traumatique donc là la personne et
comme bloquer est pas capable d'avoir
accès à certains souvenirs du passé à
cause de notre maîtrise qui est arrivé
ce qu'on sait ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau quand ça arrive mais on entend
beaucoup mettons à ce moment là qu'un kg
est d'aider des agressions qui sont
commises la personne bloc se souvenir
l'appui capables de sceller les
souvenirs sont flous à gosier quelque
chose qui s'est passé et à lui un choc
est ce qu'on sait que ce qui se passe
dans l'est dans les neurones dans les
transmettra pas il ya encore beaucoup de
recherches à faire là dessus le pont
comprend pas exactement comment ça se
fait là où au niveau moléculaire c'est
leur fuite sont donc encore beaucoup à
apprendre mais c'est vraiment un blocage
une décharge de stress énorme puis ça
serait tellement énorme que ça ça vient
comme glauque et lalush plus comme je
disais rien transfert de l'information
tu veux du bac en parallèle
grant ex bombay ce serait ce sera à l
inverse le seul empêcherait de ramener
ses souvenirs là haut niveau de
l'hippocampe pour qu'on puisse s'en
souvenir mais c'est pour ça aussi que si
ces maudits l'âme parce que ça revient
donc en force en cours
les personnes nées telle influence que
les gens peuvent avoir qu'un temps on
fait de moi quelqu'un donc dire être sûr
que tu avais pas vu ça depuis désisté
parité de cette manière là que le cortex
leur abdomen l'information mais la star
vient il pas camper à la grotte de vie
modulable donc on peut comme insérer un
souvenir qui était pas là au départ puis
la pression ça vaut three enregistré
puis il a apprécié la personne peu
revenus et sur dur comme fer que ça
s'est passé de manière alors que non
c'est les interférences qui a pu avoir
avec des personnes qui à force de
l'interroger vous posez des questions
l'emmener vers une direction qui est
fini par faire croire à la personne que
c'est arrivé de cette manière c'est fou
ce type
savez vous si des fois on dre avec des
10 des souvenirs très loin de la
jeunesse perdue si tu sais même plus si
c'est une vraie mémoire ou si une
histoire étant entendu qu'ils quittaient
markit qui sait comme crédit image c
puisque l'imagination la mémoire à cames
à nice tout se mélange un peu voyou est
tout à fait donc c'est dur de savoir des
fois jusqu'à quel point c c pure donc
c'est si quelqu'un entretient la mémoire
donc tu es un enfant il par sa
grand-mère à ces jeunes si y'a jamais de
rappel de photos plutôt et surtout si
jeune en botte 5 6 heures il va pas
avoir grand souvenir mais si cette
mémoire est en train de tenues par des
photos ou des vidéos tout ça
la lafa va voir vraiment l'impression de
l'avoir connu plus qui
et enfin jean souvenir qu'en réalité
parce que de son souvenir est réel
avec cette personne là ça se serait
effacée puis ils n'auraient pas accès à
ces moments là c'est exactement j'ai un
souvenir bouger justement ma gravats qui
décide et je pense quand j'avais 5 ans à
peu près puis j'ai un souvenir de ma
grand-mère qui ont été au centre d'un
shopi que je me suis d'abord dit à ma
mère j'ai revu tous toupie le buste ou
toulouse ma mère avait dit non puis
finalement ma grand mère elle avait
comme acheter en cachette
enfin la journée elle avait donné un
petit clin d'oeil encore surtout le sait
comme le seul souvenait que j'aime et et
en même temps comment ça s'est passé
pour vraie pile images que j'ai dans ma
tête qui est sûrement une distorsion
calme on se remet des bonnes chances
mais si une décharge émotionnelle très
grande
ça se peut que ce soit vraiment un
souvenir original ni que viennent
vraiment pour ce que c'est mais si par
exemple tu as ta mère ta grand mère te
répéter cette histoire là encore et
encore et encore
ça se peut que ce souvenir là vient de
cette répétition là ils n'ont pas dû
s'unir à partir de 15 que on commence à
emmagasiner la mémoire c'est parce
qu'ils ont on se dit qu'on va laisser
réfléchir terre notre jeunesse puis il
ya un parti qui n'existe pas dans notre
mémoire c'est à partir de 15 qu'on est
capable de commencer à faire ce trailer
puis a amené aux informations qui vont
rester pour le réseau vite fait mais on
enregistre le des déconvenues ont
commencé à enregistrer c'est mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya plein de choses qu'on me
souviens pas quand on est jeune donc
c'est quand ça quand on est plus jeune
ce car il sait qu'il ya plein
d'informations hyper importante qu'on
doit se souvenir
pour notre survie puis apprendre à vivre
en société puis avec les parents et la
famille donc c'est ceux là dessus que le
cerveau se reconcentre puis après ça va
venir des souvenirs qui sont moins
importants pour l'enfant du dédit notion
d'aidé des concepts qui sont plus
abstrait puis est capable de planifier
puis donc ça se fait dans le transport
parce que tu te fais rien de 2,6 à et
moins que notari n'a pris tu as appris
énormément te fait pas engrangé
énormément de l'information qui sont
hyper hyper important que pour toi mais
du souvenir précis de d'une faille
d'enfants ou de voyages avec les parents
petite sauce aussi trois des choses qui
vont rester très longtemps à moi que ce
soit entretenue donc ça se fait
graduellement tisser une priorité le
tice fait dans ce qui doit être
enregistrée ou pas puis au fur et à
mesure puis aussi aidé il ya des parties
du cerveau comme le cortex préfrontal
qui pour bien formé au début de camp et
jeunes s'ils continuent à se développer
jusqu'à au final la vingtaine donc ça
c'est une région du cerveau qui est
important pour la planification
l'abstraction le contrôle émotionnel
donc cette région leur cerveau étant pas
pleinement fonctionnel pas ce qui est
pas encore complètement développé ça
vient jouer aussi sur les capacités de
la personne d'enfants enregistré
certaines informations pièce qu'un
enfant mettez exemple un enfant chez pas
de deux ans qui vivrait g pourquoi un
événement entre matisse traumatisme est
traumatique chromatique x même si
mettons plutôt juillet pour un souvenir
de ces événements le il pleuvra magazine
est quand même peur d'avoir marqué
il serait honteux préval de se rappeler
de façon inconsciente puis tout mais il
peut avoir des souvenirs puis ça peut
des fois expliquer certaines pas
certaine crainte
mais cela c'est dur de jouer là dedans
parce qu'ils ont marre et consciente
ouais parce qu'on n'est plus on n'est
plus capable de super conscient non on
n'est plus capable de savoir jusqu'à
quel point ça ça le jouer
donc si l arrivée j'espère un événement
vraiment traumatisant pour l'enfant est
ici fait attaquer par des dégâts
goodkind t à 2,3 en pratique va pas s'en
souvenir comme tel samedi soir ils vont
développer une porte qui lui seraient
pas capables de comprendre les deux
est ce que ça vient du tout mais c'est
parce qu'il ya quelque chose d' associer
à ce traité géant messieurs
absolument c'était notre médecin que ça
même ça t'arrive à ces jeunes à 4,57
voiture et d'être ainsi très très jeune
d'un petit veau passionné mais ça peut
dire qu'il ya pas de disséquer les
conséquences de cette soirée c'est fou
comment la mémoire peut jouer sur
justement des réactions qu on a pendant
longtemps et c'est moi ils jugent pas
j'avais déjà raconté l'histoire le mais
on était au chalet puis il ya un an nous
vers les foyers bien de chauves-souris
qui est sorti puis 6 mai à envoyer dans
le chalet plm on part pour une raison
qui est encore à ce jour inexplicable il
si ma grille et protégez vos cheveux
comme si comme si la chaussure est à
l'espagne et dans nos cheveux qui fait
là moi je t'ai tout petit peu le
protéger ou chypre était chaud je
protège mes cheveux puis à ce jour
aussitôt que je vois une chauve souris
mais tant que je suis dans forêts dans
un chalet quelqu'un aussitôt que je vois
le chauve souris
j'ai tout le temps l'espèce de réflexe
de protéger mes cheveux capable de
raisonner le [ __ ] apporte ici mais
encore à ce jour j une espèce de porc de
mes cheveux gras grise à déconstruire ça
c'est très très dur
est-ce que des façons de le faire ben
oui les moyens de son palais
pour essayer je pense que vous n'avez
parlé aussi avec sonia lupien serait
beaucoup mieux placé mots pour expliquer
de commander construire ce genre de
souvenirs là mais ça se fait que des
thérapies qui existent puis il ya moyen
d'en arriver à voir - parra mais il va
tout à rester réduction de dette ressort
se nomme un souvenir comme moi j'ai déjà
eu par des tubes et le mieux mais dans
quel état souvenir mais ça on peut en
arriver par la logique car de comprendre
à jouer puis a pu être trop effrayé
parce c'est vraiment intéressant ce
qu'on a ce que ce que tu dirais plutôt
justement avec la personnalité en lien
avec la mémoire
finalement la personne qu'on est la
personnalité vraiment c'est la somme de
nos expériences nos mains est-ce que
c'est plus ce que quelque chose d'inédit
et j'écoute les deux roues c'est
vraiment nommé mort quand vraiment
défini de personnalités comme en
convenait beaucoup énormément
c'est ce qui m'a attiré c'est que c'est
tellement lié à qui on est et si on est
la somme de toutes les expériences qu'on
fait dans notre vie donc pis si on
réussit pas sur une de ces expériences
là non pas notre vie ce n'est pas une
petite entité ans par une autre
personnalité puis on le voit avec les
personnes les amarres le et on finit par
pu les reconnaître parce que ils sont
pus qui compte qu'ils sont ont été puis
dans ces tops cycle
moi j'ai déjà croisé la vie de quelqu'un
qui était un qui mentaient de façon
maladive le puits il y avait des
histoires qui était vraiment ancré dans
le réel mais complètement inventé puis
il lui quelqu'un tout ça est exposé lui
c'est qu'ici il se rappelait de ces
histoires le t il c'est tellement
raconté ce qui sans rappeler qui était
devenue la somme des histoires inventées
dans le fond c'est tout à fait juste
parce qu'on peut créer des souvenirs
est-ce que ça se peut dans le fond tout
à fait tout à fait
tu peux réussir à convaincre de plein de
choses puis à force de répéter quelque
chose quelqu'un peut finir par quoi que
c'est réellement arrivé puis c'est pas
le immense hall c'était pour lui c'est
vraiment survie puis da titre lange et
jamais dans ses mensonges parce que
c'était pas des mensonges pour lui
exakis ici construit un monde qui était
pas tangibles d'un rituel mais qui est
là qui est dans sa tête piquée qui est
qui qui est bien qui fait du sens pour
lui donc c'est comme quand c'est le
triste souvenir par an faisant
d'histoire mais c'est la même chose
s'était désisté ensemble réseau de
l'information qui sont cohérentes les
unes par rapport aux autres donc le
temps vient avoir un super menteur qui
dit menteur pathologique
c'était problématique dans sa vie à lui
l'effet qu'une envie en fait des gens
qui croisait le tir qu'est ce qui fait
que tim est en sachant que la mémoire
justement est imparfaite piqué est
modulable
qu'est ce qui fait que met-on justement
légalement et témoins ou séoul et de
témoignages a eu autant de pour je suis
vraiment pas en train de critiquer c'est
juste que vous comprendre parce qu'on le
sait que kessel altérables la mémoire
oui mais c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
mesures prises mis en place pour éviter
ce genre d' influence la externe pour
empêcher de déduire des faux souvenirs
aux au gens donc lié
dépressif qui existent pour pour
diminuer minimiser ça pour que cette
mémoire leur reste le plus pur possible
sans est entachée par des personnes qui
veut terminer vers à dire quelque chose
mais c'est pas c'est pas facile c'est
pour ça que des fois il y est
il ya des témoignages qui sont qu'il y
ait des personnes qui sont là pour
regarder jusqu'à quel point tous tout ça
se tient
tant pis ça reste imparfait ce moment
parfait mais la seule chose qu'on a
ben ouais inversement c'est inversement
justement qu on disait que disent
certaines des mois qu'ils sont roms
traumatique rhumatisante qui sont très
près si belle si encore justement ça
crie problème que finalement la personne
qui a vécu stromasys l'eau qui est
agressé ou quoi que ce soit puisse pas
aller il raconté d'une manière objective
d'une manière spa précise à cause de
type s'agit au contraire d'un oui tout à
fait une fois ci ils vont poser des
questions très spécifiques pilote la
pression regarde dans les journaux
pourquoi pourquoi peut pas se souvenir
des trains fret contre en elle là c'est
l'environnement contextes dans lesquels
ça c'est produit puis il ya des
mécanismes de blocage quand ça fait trop
mal à quelqu'un quelqu'un pour empêcher
d'aller vers ça puisse se faire encore
plus mal puis il ya plein de détails qui
s'occupe des fois ça va donner moins de
crédibilité à un témoignage parce que
c'est parce que c'est pas ça c'est
qu'est-ce que ça vous tente et moyens de
piloter
c'est là que se joue la game des dix
avocats haci de discréditer un
témoignage pour pour faire gagner son
client pour de folie question c'est
absurde de s'écouler couleur des rideaux
détails même pas six collectes lors des
jeunes amants qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qui arrive quand on commence à perdre la
mémoire
pourquoi ça arrive puis commencent à
arriver en fait ouais donc le meilleur
exemple de tous ses succès sur la
maladie d'alzheimer
donc pourquoi les gens ils perdent la
mémoire mais c'est c'est tout simplement
parce que les les cellules du cerveau
dans la région du cerveau qui s'occupe
des mémoires l'hippocampe meurt c'est
celle là les neurones mans donc
puisqu'on moins qu'on a deux neurones
mais ça finit par détruire les réseaux
les network puis il y en a plus assez
puis ça commence par des troupes et des
fois il y en a quelques-uns bain au
début la personne est capable de
compenser des fois on oublie à un mot on
est capable de le remplacer par un autre
concernant tout ce camp où elles font
pipi avec avec là aussi c'est normal
aussi de ne pas avoir la même acuité la
même même des grilles capacités de
mémorisation c'est ce qu'on appelait les
problèmes de mémoire subjectif donc le
la personne ce qu'on demande à ce moment
là à la personne c est ce que les dix
petits problèmes de mémoire de nuit dans
ton quotidien
si la personne dit non mais souvent
savoir rester le même
mais si la personne dit oui ça me
préoccupe puis chante dans le quotidien
l'osce à vienne perturber la si souvent
ces personnes là qui répondent de cette
manière là qui en plus de chance dans
l'hiver
la maladie d'alzheimer donc c'est là que
faut faire attention pour faire un suivi
donc c'est ça qui font au début il y
pose des questions à la personne
puis on essaye de voir jusqu'à quel
point c'est ici problème numéros sont
importantes
puis est ce qu on sait qu est ce qui
fait que les cellules morts non c'est
tout le problème
puis c'est le gars à la grande question
puis ça c'est pour le mettre en examen
mais c'est aussi pour la maladie
parkinson c'est quand on connaît pas
encore on sait pas encore pourquoi les
neurones moeurs telle est la journée
qu'on va répondre à cette question là là
on va réussir à développer des
médicaments qui sont efficaces qui vont
agir sur la source même du problème puis
le savoir ça va exploser
on va aborder les traitements
commentateurs merveilleux mais tant et
aussi longtemps cauris pas répondre
section là on va on va avoir des
médicaments qui vont régler qui vont
prévenir certains symptômes mais dati
c'est pas mal ce qu'on peut faire de
mieux est-ce que les cellules marc dans
tous les cas ce que est ce que le
vieillissement normal et c'est lui qui
m'a poussé jeu spears ont fait de
l'examen aussi drama les cellules qui
mord dans cette région le 6 lits
alzheimer
parce que c'est ce que sinon et eux
qu'on traverse à savoir ce que c'est
juste un processus normal recherche
sémantique
non c'est pas le spo parce que tu vas y
que nécessairement tous développé la
maladie dax allemand met donc dans un
cerveau de personnes saines sans mise à
mort il n'y a pas de morts
ronald d'avoir des pertes inactifs donc
ça c'est les connexions entre les
neurones qui met en danger à la base en
général va avoir un déclin dans sa
mémoire
ouais souvent ça va être des des pertes
cynapsys et ça c'est pas le neurone qui
marque comme tel qu'un excès des
déconnexions est-ce que mettons à un
juste en se rappelant de l'histoire une
connexion peut surfer ou non ben oui si
c'est répété plusieurs fois puis il y
les personnes sont encore même très
angers sont capables de se faire des
nouveaux souvenirs lui apprendre de
nouvelles choses puis il faut le faire
fonctionner le cerveau actif c'est hyper
important j'imagine que le coût de la
mise à mort c'est ce qu'il est un cas
particulier c'est vraiment difficile je
pense à a prévenu mais mettons pour
est-ce que de manière de freiner la
perte cognitive normal qu'on ville
lorsqu'on vieillit j'imagine que bâti
j'imagine qu'ils restent actifs livre
toute sa façade ou messi c'est quoi
finalement lemania de freiner ce
vieillissement le tube hey ya pas de
saint graal
il n'y a rien de magique a pas de
produits lucky vraiment là et malgré qu
le sait c'est les saines habitudes de
vie
donc il faut il faut bien s'alimenter il
faut faire de l'exercice
il faut garder son cerveau actif et il
faut rester socialement actifs aussi
donc ça c'est super important
donc si c'est juste de faire travailler
son cerveau parce que ton travail
ton cerveau travaille plus que il va
être
ça va l'aider à 1 - décliner vite dans
la maladie d'alzheimer
donc le plusieurs travaux qui commencent
à montrer que ce qu'on appelle la
réserve cognitive
donc c'est pour ça un des facteurs
préventif celle à l'éducation donc
plusieurs travaux ont montré que plus
qu'une personne est identique et puis
plus que ça va retarder l'apparition des
symptômes de la maladie
plus qu'une personne est éduqué dans sa
vie ou plus qu'une personne continue à
s'éduquer au fil du temps exactions au
fil du temps donc c'est pas juste
je peux maintenant aux yeux des faits
versus universités mais qu'à 25 ans tu
arrêtes de te dis que ça se change rien
exact donc ce que y'a lisez dessus de
university petit os et c'est pas mauvais
mais il faut toujours continuer à
apprendre des choses restez connectés
informés sur ce qui se passe dans le
monde sur lez lille notre famille nos
amis fait face à des ddd calcul mental
d'aider des activités ce document
croisille payer toutes ses défauts dit
même but du jeu virtuel où on pratique
la mémoire spatiale tout ça eide a gardé
est ce qu'elle est ce que la retraite
c'est pas un peu un couteau à double
tranchant
en ce sens les quais tri qui à partir du
poids 65k
je deviens tu es un peu un peu plus aux
oisifs un peu moitié j'optais - je te
prends en plus sédentaire ma mon travail
et mon cerveau parce que je suis j'ai pu
travailler hors dons est ce que ce
serait finalement ce modèle ne fait pas
accélérer un petit peu le vieillissement
partir de ce moment dans le bain tout à
fait si la personne on entrevoit la
retraite de cette manière là
il se dirige vers une pente déclinante
donc il faut vraiment comme il ya un
article qui paraît dans des vingt-sept
où ils montrent qu'il ya douze risque
modifiables kiki qui peuvent expliquer
40% des codes démence
donc si on joue sur ces facteurs de
risques là on peut avoir un impact réel
sur l'apparition plus la progression de
la maladie d'alzheimer
ah ouais donc là on parlait de
d'éducation se sent ni à l'égard des
actifs pressés aux étudiants un trou
d'un coup au début du spam à l'éducation
après c'est un milieu de vie
puis un peu plus tard donc un milieu de
vie sait plus faire attention à peu
développé d'hypertension d'obésité
donc ça c'est hyper important
puis après ça en fin de vie ben c'est
plus pour 6 lits socialement et éviter
la dépression
faire du sport pas être obèse pas de
diabète
donc ça c'est si on accumule toutes ces
facteurs l'eau puis on y fait attention
on peut pour devrait avoir n'est pas
créée elle peut on parle de deux
traitements mais juste juste l'empêcher
d'arriver était montré que s'ils ont
réussi à retarder de seulement deux ans
l'apparition de la maladie d'alzheimer
c'est 34% de moins de gens qui auraient
besoin de se retrouver un dandy des
maisons de soins de longue durée
donc je 2-1 juste 2 1 pour le tiers des
jaguars parce que à cet âge là ils sont
rangés les gens se regardaient à ces
vielles où il peut arriver beaucoup
d'autres choses qui va faire que la
personne va décider ça avant que
développe la maladie
quand tu parles de contacts sociaux de
garder des contacts sociaux longtemps et
il est ce que tu crois qu'avec la
situation actuelle la queue vide ou est
ce qu'il ya eu des personnes âgées qui
ont été forcés de rester à l'intérieur
chez eux ne jamais sortir dans plusieurs
dans plusieurs endroits de soins dans
même dans les maisons en fait le tri est
ce que tu entrevoit qui voit une hausse
due de l'apparition de symptômes de
maladie d'alzheimer dans cette
génération là qui leur étaient comme
limite est encore actif mais quel autre
jour au lendemain on les empêche d'aller
voir leurs amis le mort dit d'aller
jouer aux cartes le vendredi 2 comme de
côtoyer d'autres gens c'est sûr que ç'a
joué comme si l'isolément social des
pressions manque d'activité physique
donc si comme jc tout des facteurs de
respirer le confinement que les
personnages y ont subi en urgence de
genre de problème donc nécessairement
salue un rôle à jouer puis il ya aussi
calé ces personnes là et on y ont été
coupées de gens qui aiment pis c c'est
hyper important pour eux pour diminuer
leur anxiété leur stress sur une
situation qui comprend pas vraiment leur
retient et tout déstabilisé aussi c'est
c'est la routine est hyper important
pour ces personnes-là donc 15,60
déstabilisé par rapport à sa salle a un
impact certain sur plusieurs symptômes
de la maladie comme les problèmes de
mémoire et vont s'accentuer plus de
problèmes d'attention plus d'apathie
donc des trucs et mes frères qui
maintenant ils trouvent moins d'intérêt
cc titre est en fait le succès de ses
deux mètres c'est parce que c'est moi je
me suis juste pas incité à mon grand
parc est encore super en forme ultime
est que mais qui s'est fait dire tu peux
aller voir des amis lui qu'il était
chanceux parce que pendant d'une tht
encore dans sa maison ont pu y aller
neymar chaque sa blonde qui est encore
super actif qui avait sa blonde aussi
pour être ensemble c'est fake mais je
pense après le monde comme ceux qui ne
pouvaient plus sortir peu forcée c'est
triste comment les les grands ports à
mon ex copine justement lui sait il est
toujours resté super actif
intellectuellement lahti le journal
continuité lits décédés en 2019 puis
vraiment jusque là toute fine l'outil
était super allumé encore pu nous
raconte aidé beaucoup d'histoires de sa
jeunesse beaucoup d'histoires de sa vie
typique c'était suis pas prêt si ce parc
lors des faits qui verra moi est
vraiment entretenu cultiver sa mémoire
tpiy toujours les mêmes histoires aussi
là vous rencontrer béliveau le jour
d'heure qui j'avais les jambes il vole
semaine mais est-ce que ce pas à lui
mais pire il est tombé malade il ya
comme une fête digne manif ça donne
beaucoup beaucoup affaibli qui sur sa
mémoire sa part eu c'est comme s'il ya
eu un vraiment un lien direct qui est
décédée par l'ontt antilles avec 92 m
avait fêté le fond de cette affaire ça
peut vraiment jouer puis vers la fin
logique qu'on allait le voir à l'hôpital
c'était comme si toutes les mémoires et
ml a complètement mélanger puis c zéro
est rapidement mais là c'est comme une
seconde on était dans la pièce avec lui
après celui il jouait même en europe il
parle à son frère ou de ses fils était
comme si la presse toute sa vie tu es
mélanger puis il passait d'une place à
l'oti dit rendu s'est rendus incohérents
mais c'était quand même des mémoires
andric hip hop épiler tout d'un coup
c'est solidité hadopi lui parle à son
frère ou ici sous un tipi littérateurs
restaurant tout d'un coup c'est comme si
les mémoires et prenez comme le dessus
de la réalité vraiment pour moi tout
allait bien on comprend mal à digérer ce
faut comprendre que c'est très rare de
maladie d'alzheimer pure ce sera avec
une comorbidité il a si souvent
[Musique]
elle qui le plus ancien que les agences
et les problèmes cardiovasculaires donc
les démences rascle accessoires une pâte
une démence mixte eyes à mort et
vasculaires et ça ça vient jouer
beaucoup sur le mort tout dépendant que
salles arrive donc en comprend si un
accident cérébrovasculaire qui se
produit donc un caillou d'un lapin quand
vous dit pas combien on comprend que sa
savane un pas très important parce que
le conte bloc un vaisseau ou s'ils
explosent hémorragique bain et il va
avoir des dommages qui va titre dans
cette région du cerveau plus ou moins
importantes tout dépendamment la halle
halal parce que des fois des cailloux ça
peut rester sur très longtemps donc ce
sera créé plus de dommage c'est un petit
caillou puis il disparaît demain soir au
moins un pack
donc ça c'est après ça dépend de
l'ampleur de l'accident ses roues à ce
qu'il arrive puis ou que ça se produit
parce que si cela se produit une fois ça
il peut y avoir une armée qui sont
silencieuses des rues dans des régions
du cerveau où ça n'affecte pas la
paresse elle affecte la mémoire c'est la
fête pour ses fonctions motrices en
personne s'en rend compte et il se dit
que c'est s'est rien passé on s'en rend
compte qu'un une fonction à quelque part
qui fonctionne pas comme ça c'était
habituellement salles arrive beaucoup
pour la maladie d'alzheimer parce que si
on bloque certains vaisseaux plus que
les versions son groupe plus fort aussi
que ça va aura un impact important
filles aussi que ce qui se passe dans la
mondialisation c'est qu'il ya des
protéines on tire on ne sait pas d'où
vient la mort neuronale mai
certaines protéines qu'on sait qu'ils
pourraient à tout le moins joué un rôle
d peut tout expliquer la mort neuronale
mais une partie de la mort neuronale
donc c'est des protéines qui s'appelle à
mulhouse de bêta et eux ce qui s'est
produit c'est que t'as s'accumulent dans
le cerveau puis c'est surtout pendant sa
main s'éclairer c'est éliminer du
cerveau mais si donc ça ça va dans le
csf dansant puis on élimine demain mais
si ces livres sont bloqués mais c'est
celle à une pauvre ça en pas ici une
bonne élimination de cette protéine
l'oeil à + d'accumulation puis il ya
plus de perte inutile de contacter les
neurones et éventuellement sa publiera
la mort neuronale
mon grand pas ce monde là pas du tout
pensé qu'ils aient fait de l'examen mais
par un clash des petits systèmes commune
après cela les amap y en as far as
récemment mon père est médecin ainsi pis
on parlait récemment de j comme on
parlait de la mode et de la mode de
montréal qui dit moi quand j'avais 10
ans
pizza ses pouces avait de la ramasse et
de la démence vasculaire fait que c'est
ce que tu décris dans ces cas la
connexion en fait le cerveau passée
alimentée finalement parce que des
vaisseaux qui sont bloqués exactions
laissant à porto cervo nutriments et
indigènes
donc s'il manque un t2 et ingrédients là
c'est sûr qu'il va avoir des
répercussions plus ou moins grande tout
dépendamment conduit où ça se produit
depuis combien de temps ça va durer fait
dans le fond dans ces colosses ac/dc les
vaisseaux sanguins
tellement qu'ils sont ensemble qui quand
et bloquer ou keep est occupé à toi qui
régit ces poursuit ses excuses pour ce
qu'elle y en obésité etc malade il est
ce parce que tant qu'on est conçu de
visiter y ait plus de chance que les
super tension tout m'était tv soa
à mal quand l hypertension parce qu'ils
deviennent plus plus gros plus tendu
donc le 6e plus de chances de kiki qui
pert pitié qui trie des hémorragies
quand l'un des facteurs de risque aussi
de la maladie d'alzheimer
donc s'il est sûr d'hypertension mettre
plus de chances de développer la maladie
tantôt dessus mentionné le par kingson
qui est aussi ou est ce qu'elle est les
neurones mort en fait le puits pour le
parkinson
il y à un traitement d'amener une
électrode dans une zone précise du
cerveau but de stimuler cette zone
l'appui de régler ou de contrôler les
symptômes du parkinson est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui qui est possible aussi
avec les amants c'est quelque chose qui
études et recherches qui sont dans cette
danse est sans cela parce qu'une fois
que la classe zone du cerveau où est ce
que les neurones mort comment ça en fait
et est ciblé est ce que c'est une
possibilité éventuelle sur vous ça
pourrait être une possibilité
présentement à ce que ce qu'on a comme
traitement c'est la l dopa donc dans la
même gamme donc la mise à mort c'est la
mort de rené qui se produit très tôt
dans un contexte online campent dans la
même dit par kingson sort encore c'est
la même chose c'est de la mort neuronale
on sait pas encore pourquoi mais ça se
produit dans un autre région du cerveau
qui s'appelle la substance noire
puis elle avait projeté envoyer notre
corps c'est la décennie renault sont
dans le stand mans et projette dans
d'autres régions du cerveau le striatum
donc la voix ni duros triés puis il
meurt très tôt pis c'est la même chose
le cerveau est capable de composer
compenser très longtemps dit yvan auront
jusqu'à 40 50 % de morts dans cette
région du cerveau avant que la personne
commence à sentir des cinq tombes dont
qui citerait tuzaguet pas de nouvelles
cellules qui serait mis énormément quand
même de plasticité donc les neurones qui
meurent et les autres aux alentours
environnants mais ils vont prendre la
relève ils vont faire des ddd réseau
d'aidé snav qui il s'est un peu comme ça
qui ont compensé le monde ni la morale
est tellement importante que l'oeil
le slam une pipe capable de deal avec
puis les symptômes apparaît donc et il
l'a donc dans les neurones qui parle de
l'assurance mans vers le sera tom cegid
pour ce qu'on appelle les neurones
dopaminergiques
donc il finit par manquer dopamine dans
le striatum donc c'est pour ça qu'on
donne la l dopa donc c'est un sas a
traversé la berme et oz fallait que ça
rentre dans le cerveau puis ça vient
compenser la mort des neurones
dopaminergiques en fournissant la
dopamine qui est qui qui ment quand donc
ça c'est ce qui se fait après solde dans
des modèles animaux bon on peut faire
des stimulations électriques dans ces
régions du cerveau puisse avoir avoir un
impact positif parce que même si en
reste - ont réussi à les stimuler pour
favoriser la libération de dopamine puis
venir compenser un peu le manque de
dopamine qui ont déjà à la mort des
neurones mais ce on comprend que tout
cela fonctionne tant et aussi longtemps
qu'ils respirent en aucun cas la mode ne
veut rien devient trop important qu'elle
avait dit mais le traitement est fait
dans l'est dans les phases au début de
la maladie avant que ça devienne trop
trop avancé exact c'est aussi pour les
traitements aussi de la maladie
d'alzheimer c'est que il ya certains
médicaments qui ne fonctionne pas c'est
tout le monde puis qui sait certains
surtout pour certains symptômes sans une
certaine période de tapis dans cette
période de temps mais c'est souvent au
début de la maladie note on partait on
parlait d'une membrane alias système
durand qui s'appelle acétylcholine donc
cholinergiques puis il sa mort très vite
dans la maladie donc on va faire la même
chose quand comme il manque de ces
neurones là on va on va augmenter le
nouveau transmetteur qui est qui qui
manque la cité les collines en venant
bloquer son sa dégradation
donc ça permet à l'acide colline d'agir
plus longtemps sur les neurones depuis
que venir compenser la mort neuronale
que l'énergie donc c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire pour la mise en examen mais
c'est la même idée condamné qu'à y en a
plus il y en a 8 a beau essayer de
stimuler avec un ami cher la cycline des
gardes et qu'il n'y a plus assez de city
connais juste place et c'est pour ça que
c'est limité dans le temps c'est ce
genre de traitement
tu parlais des douze facteurs je peux
vraiment apprécié exactement facteurs de
risque météo qui peut qui peut
contribuer augmenter les chances de
développer ce mode d amal est ce que
quelqu'un qui aurait une gêne de ville
vraiment super
paris d'actifs intellectuellement actif
aussi mange bien dors bien posté c'est
est ce que quelqu'un peut tout bien fait
mais est ce que quelqu'un pourrait
vraiment avoir une bonne hygiène de vie
quand même développé sans qu'on sache
pourquoi
mais oui mais oui évidemment donc tout
ça c'est des facteurs de risque
tabou tout faire à la perfection ça va
diminuer t shirt et chansons mais tu
peux pas faire du tout juste dix minutes
et charles la méditation 30 minutes à
tous les matins pinet a voté d'abord une
chienne de vie
ewan garder actif puis jusqu'à arrive
car celles ci doivent cesser au dessus
c'est une balance de ta vie de ce que tu
veux ta vie puis on s'est juste nous on
met ça sur la dame ont été regardées
l'oeil les des facteurs de risque sont
modifiables
après ça c'est à toi de faire telle
décision peut décider qu est ce que tu
encore pas ou pas dans ton temps tu es
dans l'hygiène de vie pire +80 incorporé
puis plus que ça risque de
une allée mais après ça c'est les
facteurs environnementaux puis il y en a
d'autres où il ya des facteurs aussi
qu'ils seront génétique de bois voire
l'hygiène de vie tu veux tu peux pas
passer à côté ses yeux de moisissures de
l'alzheimer dans ta famille
quelles sont les chances que ça se
transmettent de génération en génération
que tu as du district sont faites sur le
quel point ça peut être dans les gènes
oui donc il ya certaines femmes qui sont
héréditaires mais c'est très alors donc
il ya comme deux alzheimer minimum donc
il y forme sporadique la maladie
d'azheimer donc l'on connaît pas encore
les causes que l'on parle de récits de
99% des cas puis un petit pourcentage le
un peu près 1% ou s'est délité formes
familiales les femmes famille a cédé des
limitations que dans certains gènes qui
va augmenter le risque de développer la
maladie d'alzheimer
donc c'est pas parce que tout ce que
j'ai lu que nécessaire matures à
développer mettre plus de chance
puisqu'il est observable ce gène est ce
qu'on peut lui même temps on peut
l'analyser non plus trop haut il peut
faire des dédicaces de salies vous en
voyez ça un laboratoire vous revient
avec l'it est ce qu'il vous dira que
vous avez comme le plus grand facteur de
risque génétique pourrait l'y forme
sporadique de la mezam à ces engins qui
s'appelle à pau 4 donc s'il ya un nom
qui est une protéine qui juste
différente savoir donc est là
à vous 2 3 4 c'est la 4 communautés
donc si cette forme le khimki qui semble
augmenter le risque de développer la
maladie d'alzheimer
donc si ce n'est cet hymne aux femmes le
bain si c'étaient deux copies de ses
gènes hla met à peu près de 12 fois plus
de chances de développer la maladie
d'alzheimer
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya très
peu de personnes qui ont conduit copie
de thuyas à peu près 1 2% de la
population qu'on de copies de la pauvre
4 ce qui est quand même ce qui est quand
même content 2 % de personnes sur dix
sur cinq ans même le moins deux
personnes pour sa part négligeable mais
ça augmente les risques possédait pas
prédestiné à la même solide du copil il
y en a qui kills 12% plus de chance il
tresse des chances de près la piste en a
eu une belle hausse est plus répandue
l'on parle à peu près 25% de la
population
mais tout est à peu près de trois fois
plus de chances de développer la zone et
on sait comment le jeune facteur de
risque génétique le plus important pour
la forme sporadique et ceux qui comme le
second bien qu'on parlait justement de
tout bien faire pour diminuer les
risques de de le développer mais
j'imagine que si justement de ces bonnes
habitudes de vie le 6 on était pour le
développer en réseau développé plus tard
à yes peut-être que oui peut-être que
non on peut mourir demain d'un hôte
d'autres choses avant d'avoir eu le
temps de développer la maladie
d'alzheimer
dans tous les cas vous mourrez
à la mort j'ai compris tu veux pas
mourir mais c'est pas mal ce qui au bout
de chemin
moi je suis je suis végétalien dans vie
puis quand je suis devenu végétalien il
ya beaucoup de monde qui me disait
attention oméga 3 pour la mémoire pour
la capacité sur s ou c'est juste la
bullshit calcul de de manquer de mega 3
pourrait mener vers une perte de mémoire
ouvert des moins bonnes capacités
cognitives au niveau 2 donc on apprend
qu'en alimentation donc oméga 3 ils
disaient tous qu'ils ont été faits de
suppléments oméga 3 puis dans une bonne
revue la jam neurologique qui ont pas vu
des faits de suppléments oméga 3 j'ai pu
mais il n'y aura peut-être quelque chose
pour justement si quelqu'un les jeunes à
bord quatre ans après éventuellement
avoir un impact mais ça ça reste à être
sais pas encore il ya encore de
recherche enfin ce serait peut-être mais
oméga 3 celle ci est incorporé dans des
centres habitudes de vie dans le régime
alimentaire qui est le mieux le sait le
méditerranéen on l'appelle le mind
du poisson plus légumes donc poissons
légumes fruits ont donc c'est pas mal la
base de ce régime là puis naissant mais
ça va pas d'abord c'est après ça c'est
l'idée de supplémentation parce que
c'est cela un effet réel ou pas d'un
candidat méga 3 ça semble pas être le
cas
puis en termes d'alimentation est ce
qu'il ya d'autres pistes de qui ont été
recherchées qui peuvent qui peuvent
permettre de lutter contre la perte de
mémoire ou le développement de maltazard
bah ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
regardé au apprécié au niveau des dix
vitamines donc par exemple la vitamine d
donc ils ont remarqué qu'une carence
dans le sens des vitamines des amendes
de 3 fois les chances de développer la
maladie d'alzheimer
mais conséquence elle considéré oui mais
on ne sait pas encore si c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait une supplémentation en vitamine
d est ce que ça va ordonner un impact
réel sur la survenue de la maladie dans
la main donc on sait qu'il ya un manque
puis quand il en manque ça peut
développer c'est pas nécessairement dire
que en théorie ça devrait marcher mais
encore une fois ça reste à prouver
puis est ce que c'est le même principe
mais tant que le thème des qu'avec le
méga trop de dire juste dans leur petit
soleil tu prends des vitamines des mets
ton est ce que s'élèvent à régler ton
problème de carence versus la
supplémentation temps exact donc si on a
une bonne alimentation diversifiée qui
libre et qui se ressent quasiment
absolument tout ce qu'il faut dans ton
alimentation puisse pas besoin de
rajouter quoi que ce soit pour avoir une
bonne dizaine d'études élémentaires
donc après ça c'est quand il ya des
carences comme pour la vitamine a si une
carence le
le fait de rajouter des suppléments de
vitamine k pourrait aider diminue les
risques de développer la maladie de gens
ne s'étaient pas de carence en vitamine
e m a pas besoin de supplémentation
faire attention que les vitamines
parce que ça s'accumule puissions on en
prend trop le ca veut développer 10 des
problèmes d'ostéoporose dafri gili tu es
donc faut faire il part attention faut
consulter puis vous demander où nous
mettions ce n'est pas là-dessus parce
que sa revente clip que ça peut pas être
dangereux
- tout en faire attention le camp ont
commencé à jouer avec sa femme au régime
ou soigner adrien gagnon womé puis ou
est ce que quelqu'un sont les dernières
découvertes les plus les plus
prometteuses par rapport à ceux par
rapport à l'alzheimer ou est ce qui en
est la science était vraiment en terme
de coaching age ii sciences par rapport
à ceux ok donc se contracter rien sortir
à terme du médicament me disent ah mais
ça remonte au début des années 2000
l'ombre et ebics adam khel l'ami martin
il y avait sorti sopi salaires certains
effets positifs certaine période de
temps au début de la maladie mais depuis
il n'y a rien qui qui est sorti parce
qu'on souffre qu'on fait rien dans la
boule
il ya énormément de recherches qui sait
c'est juste que pour l'instant il n'y a
rien qui aboutit pour plusieurs raisons
mais mais ce que ce qui est beaucoup
étudié ce qui est beaucoup en avance
ainsi ce qu'on appelle l'hypothèse
amyloide beta donc on en a parlé un
petit peu tout à l'heure est une
protéine qui qui qui s'accumulent dans
le cerveau qui s'agrège un cerveau qui
forment des plaques les plaques
amyloïdes
puis quand il est sous forme solide donc
avant de formuler plaque non qu'ils se
font selon lui il serait un neurotoxique
donc ils créeraient des pertes inapte et
puis et puis c'est intéressant parce que
c'est
une pathologie la pathologie en bêta qui
arrive très tôt dans la maladie de
l'examen donc avant même les problèmes
de mémoire qui trouvent qu'un type léger
on voit cette alimentation l'au delà de
l'habitat soluble ok donc on s'y disent
on joue les tubes on veut pouvoir
réussir à retarder tout le reste tout le
reste
donc il ya eu beaucoup d'argent qui a
été investie sylla d'appui pour le
moment il n'y a rien qui a porté fruit
il n'y a rien qui arrive et qui a été
approuvé par exemple relève didier rebut
sur le marché là il y en a un pour
l'instant qui s'appelle être qu'un imam
donc ça vient ça vient ça c'est
d'immunothérapie aux beta donc tu te
prends mais des anticorps contre la
mélodie de bêta pour empêcher qu'elle et
son effets neurotoxiques puis l'ont
nathalie lille la réponse de la fda food
and drug administration pour savoir si
ou non ça va être approuvé ça devrait
arriver courant de 2021 mais mais il ya
eu pas mal de controverses encore par
rapport à ça parce que c'est basé sur
plusieurs études et des essais cliniques
puis un essai clinique avait pas rien de
noble après ce soir plongez dans l'île
les données puis en regardant plus
attentivement en regardant parce que
d'exposer ses techniques faut réajuster
lits d'hôpitaux playoffs
ameganvi si on prend ces personnes là
quand une certaine dose pendant un
certain temps puis doubler ça ça semble
fonctionner puisque sommes deux espèces
de deux rapports qui sont faut qu'on
peut dans le même sens les experts au
niveau de la f10 il faut qu'il va lui
c'est comme ça que ces questions quand
tu vois puis jusqu'à quel point le
bénéfice risque
puis ici s'ils donnent le québec
bombay un séisme il ya plus de bénéfices
que de risques donc il ça risque
d'arriver sur le marché mais faut pas
s'attendre à ce que ça soit miraculé
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'un qu'on apprend
qu'il soit on est on commence à
développer la maison mère ou un proche
qui est c'est quoi qui recommandait
finalement team et on pourrait peut-être
freiné le plus possible le développement
de ce seuil est quelque chose qu'on peut
faire ou si faut apprendre à vivre avec
puis premièrement fallu chercher de
light donc il faut faire fort par les
faux pas avoir pas fait pas s'isoler par
rapport à ça donc il faut faire pour
passer toutes les heures et les examens
qu'il faut parce que des fois ça peut
être confondue avec d'autres choses
s'est confondue avec la la la dépression
si on regarde les symptômes
il ya beaucoup de symptômes que l'on
voit chez les personnes dépressives t
des problèmes de mémoire d'attention de
problèmes d'abstraction planification
abbiati ça rentre coupe beaucoup de
symptômes qu'on voit en dépression et
puis après ça ou ça peut être mélangé à
une démence vasculaire
donc il faut passer différents ts pour
voir est ce que c'est vraiment ou pas la
maladie d'alzheimer
parce que si c'est par exemple une
démence vasculaire ce que ceux-ci
traitable ou vraiment non parce qu'une
fois que le caillou c'est fait qui sait
il y être autant la pression peut donner
des dix ans pour revenir désépaissir
l'aca pour empêcher que des formations
caillou pipi tout ça mais
une fois que cet arrêt ou un vaisseau
s'ouvre mais il s'est ouvert après faut
juste laisser le corps le temps de deux
deals avec 15 que met-on en moyenne je
reviens qui savary vraiment d'école mais
je ma question est en deux parties
qu'est ce que ça peut arriver mais ton
des signes avant-coureurs de medzamor
pis comment on les reconnaît avant il ya
plusieurs signes avant qu'on soit
atteint la proprement dit de la maladie
d'alzheimer donc parce que j'imagine que
de la poigne end avance tout le temps
mieux oui c'est ça puis beaucoup de
richesse qui se fait aussi pour
développer des biomarqueurs précoces de
la maladie d'alzheimer donc avant même
d'avoir la main stage jusqu'à on
commence à voir des pertes de mémoire de
les détecter le plus tôt possible pour
réagir le plus tôt possible même si on
ne peut médicaments pour le moment je
pense que c'est pas intéressant d'avoir
des biomarqueurs parce que ça permet de
deux de jouer sur l'île les habitudes de
vie donc tu ici on apprend qu'il ya des
chances plus de chance que tu développes
et jaillit ils vont prendre des
meilleures habitudes de vie vont faire
on faire plus de sport et moi si tu veux
faire plus attention est gardée
intellectuellement active
c'est donc qu'ils aient diminué
l'hypertension aussi si la personne est
obèse
enfin plus de sport donc il ya des
choses à faire puisque c'est pas
négligeable comme je sais c'est 40 pour
ça que peu été illuminé donc est quand
même beaucoup afin donc vers cas ça peut
arriver
oui ce fils quels sont les signes
avant-coureurs donc plus après ça donc
pour les signes avant-coureurs donc ça
arrive avant la maladie donc il y trop
subjective donc ton pose la question est
ce que ça vous dérange dans votre
quotidien cela personne dit oui elle le
médecin va faire comment on fait pour se
rendre jusqu'à ce qu'un médecin nous
pose cette question le sait maintenant
je me dis le thé chez nous le plus
commun ce que je me rends compte que
j'ai besoin d'aller me faire poser cette
question le médecin et le ton le 5e 44
veepee tant parlé tout à l'heure de
comment le cerveau trouvent des façons
d'éviter le type fait qu'à place mais
ton de dire le mot table j'utilise le
plan sûr que ça référé une table en
planches de voir que jonathan tu es
quelqu'un
intuitivement je vais changer certains
mots que j'oublie puis que je continue
ma vie je me rends même pas moi même
complètement comment qu'on fait pour se
rendre jusqu'à ce qu'un médecin lui
demande d'être que sa venue au quotidien
tricoit donc apprécié ces différentes
personnes tu es avec font plus attention
qui sont plus préoccupés donc dès qu'un
petit 14 vont aller voir le médecin dès
que ça peut être détecté plus tôt
mais habituellement les gens quand ils
vont consulter son conduire à des
troubles cognitifs légers donc c'est là
la phase promis que la maladie
d'alzheimer donc avant puisque tout le
monde qui ont des trucs une typologie
qui ont tous progressé dans la mise à
mort il y en a certains qui ont la dent
qui vont convertir un pur puis devenir
un alzheimer
donc ceux qui sont à ce stade là
également ce qu'on voit là comme
symptôme le le plus souvent c'est les
des problèmes à souvenirs de certains
mots de certaines ont des problèmes à
faire des tâches plus qu'ils sont plus
complexes ou au travail
donc ça c'est d'éditer des signes que le
peut-être quelque chose ou réussir à
bien s'orienter dans des endroits qui
sont pas familiers nécessairement la
présence était encore capable de
s'orienter chez elles ou dans les
basques à connaît bien métier sommes
arrivés dans un nouvel aéroport
le c6 est très chargé pour la personne
puis la paroisse des problèmes à
s'orienter
mais non c'est encore ce petit et puis
c'est triste c'est pas objectif mais il
peut avoir plus apprécié d'avoir des
tests cognitifs qu'on appelle qui
peuvent être passé pour essayer de voir
ce que oui ou non il ya de quoi
s'inquiéter
ce qui souvent est ce que plus souvent
qu'autrement c'est les personnes mêmes
qui réalise le problème ici c'est les
proches et l'entourage qui font quelque
chose qui est bizarre avec
avec bob et les deux donc des fois c'est
la rando troubles cognitifs légers des
fois c'est la personne mais bien souvent
ça va être des personnes de l'entourage
de m ils étaient quelque chose parce que
domingo ont vu ni connu des passages
fatigué donc mais parce qu'on est trop
de temps aussi si nous fait des fois et
d'avoir un regard extérieur de nos
proches qui nous voit assez
régulièrement
lui peut des fois mieux détecter que
nous que la tête quelque chose de simple
qui essayait c'est plus que des pertes
de normal de toutes les actions typique
il est souvent des choses qui reviennent
de comment j'ai remarqué tel
comportement chez mes parents à l'orangé
ma mère a rangé les fourchettes os
qu'amélie cuir d'habitude ou d'affaires
ce qui est ce qui est dit justement déjà
des signes typiques qui convoie ou qui
revient souvent au niveau des troubles
cognitifs légers il y en a pas tant que
ça c'est ce qui rend la chose difficile
parce que c'est si subtile donc faut
vraiment faire attention et très
attentif puis et puis c'est tout le
temps par rapport à l'état d'avant donc
si la personne ne retient pas les noms
d'acteurs parce que non en fait du nom
d'acteur le tilt pose une question et
une étude lui qui a été joué dans la
dentelle films n'ont rien d'anormal
je vais dire mais si c'est quelqu'un qui
suit les livres qu'ils lisent actually
revue peut-être les historiens pas dans
l'atelier tic quelque chose s'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une éco personne
si toi tu oublies tacler jours pour
faire genre crise comme tu es mais
laissez moi si j'oublie ma clé plusieurs
fois ça se peut de ce fait il faut aller
munoz santé
ça va jamais ça n'est pas vraiment la
personne enfin le prix exact pour ça
c'est sympa c'est pour ça que vous êtes
attentif c'est pas comme un action égal
c'est en fonction de la personne de son
véhicule de ses expériences personnelles
après essayer des tests standardisés ils
n'ont qu'à il y en a deux par exemple
comme le mms est donc minime en toast et
examinations puis elle le moc a donc
monté au times allait voir les tests
je vous conseille d'aller le voir avant
c'est tout le temps les mêmes questions
c'est ainsi standardisés donc c'est sûr
30 puis le là la personne pose les
questions puisqu'il faut que ce soit
fait par un professionnel puisque une
manière de poser les questions de faire
de dakar puis tout seul donc fini par
créer un billet dans peace et ça ils
vont y va lui l'orientation dans
l'espace calcul mental la mémoire si ce
genre de choses là qui vont avec lui
puis ils vont arriver avec la complicité
dans un certain age mais le traité plus
comme un actif légers puis si après un
certain score bleu tu vas tu es tombé
dans le début d'une maladie nazaire puis
le monde qui nous occupe les ions
majoritairement 18 34
est ce que est ce que ça peut arriver
jeunes comme ce puits puis j'imagine que
le monde dont plus atteints à l'affût
pour leurs parents mais qu'est ce que ça
peut arriver jeunes comme ce nom c'est
très rare les lily cole est plutôt bien
il ya tout un des exceptions il y en a
la trentaine mais c'est extrêmement rare
le site va céder des décos familiale
donc ceci série d'entaillés de mutation
dans un gène puis le savez ça peut se
développer plus tôt mais c'est très rare
quand on parle de ses 20% de la
population à partir de
de 65 ans puis dans la tranche 85 89 ans
s'est rendu vains pour ça donc à partir
de 85 ans le risque double à chaque 5
c'est vraiment associé avec la mspa
on le sait que la wii c'est le facteur
de risque numéro 1 de loin pas encore
toutes les autres risques et on comprend
pas encore on n'est pas grave de fer
capable de faire des liens pourquoi la
houle fini par créer le nouveau
dégénérescence qu'on voit dans la mise à
il est couplé semaine de ce mois ci il y
avait une femme charmante monde en parle
qui étaient atteintes d'alzheimer
précoce pour raconter son histoire est
va être d'un quarantaine d'un
cinquantaine de maires des familles et
des enfants à la maison
demandez l'aide médicale à mourir -
c'était super cet espace tristesse pas
toujours été d'avoir quelqu'un d'aussi
jeune piquet est raccord jeu particulier
puisque carbone pur comme expliquer son
problème était à al ses piles mais c'est
lyon d'ici une couple d'années
ça va être terminé sans doute le tipi
est prévu l'émission là mais j'imagine
que c'était un col ajustement des très
rares cas de maladie d'alzheimer
familial avec des mutations dans
certains jeunes est ce que est ce que
quelqu'un qui est vraiment avancer parce
que quelqu'un qui est vraiment avancer
la maladie d'alzheimer qui reconnaît
plus les épreuves qui reconnaît plus les
gens qui lui ont parcouru sa vie ça peut
être vraiment difficile pour les proches
d'essayer d'être là pour cette personne
chez un enfant qui qui fait pas à son
parent parce qu'il le reconnaît plus de
tisser c'est vraiment challenge à metz
que les gens qui qui qui sont comme ça
avance et ont malgré tout besoin de
leurs proches avec eux ou sap et puis
aucune différence pour un os est hyper
important même s'ils reconnaissent plus
même si soit l'heure
c'est important pour pas qu'ils sentent
isolées socialement je garde ce qui
reste de l'armée mort de le garder actif
en parlant en faisant des interactions
sociales
donc c'est ici hyper important même si
des fonds il vaut plus rien le reconnaît
plus et c'est quoi le point d'y aller
pour un sommet non non c'est hyper
important pour la personne la personne
continue à des innovations puis même si
à ce n'est pas tout la présence jusqu'à
présence d'un être cher autour d'elle
volet dis à ta a progressé moins moins
vite
il ya des histoires qu'on entend
quelqu'un qui qui qui est sur point de
décéder que ça fait des années qu'il
reconnaît plus son entourage qui au
moment de quitter petite histoire
ésotérique qui sont transformés qui
moment quitter comme un instant de
lucidité dans son dans sa tête le tipi
monsieur j'ai entendu plusieurs fois ce
genre d'histoires lost quelque chose qui
est qui réel c'est quelque chose qui
arrive au vrai oui ça arrive surtout au
début de la maladie parce qu'on
s'imagine tout à la maladie comme
quelque chose de progresser de linéaire
d'un lit énorme c'est paul qu il ya des
moments de lucidité
des fois il ya des grands moments comme
une journée n'y a rien à faire
souviennent de riscle la journée d'après
a alors un souvenir ou une pensée donc
si c'est oui une continuité une
progression mais dans cette progression
l'oeil il ya dix ans pendant ces c'est
parce qu'on le voit plus appréciés des
moments du liban nawaf plus tard mais
ils vont devenir de moins en moins vrai
qu'un certain qu est ce que une fois
qu'une personne arrive au point que qui
est plus du tout autonome qui reconnaît
plus ses proches péter vraiment vraiment
avancé est ce qui est dit qu est ce que
ça doit quand même assez longtemps sa
période là ça peut être très long donc
souvent l'école est plus agressif donc
l'hélico familiale n'arrive plus tôt
puis sont plus agressifs quand cela
arrive plutôt bien ça va se développer
sur plus long terme soit la personne va
décéder avant de développer des
symptômes très très important de la
maladie donc ce que tout système
fonctionne un peu quand on aurait là on
vit au ralenti donc le métabolisme des
services la même chose les sauces et ça
fait plus plus lentement dans le temps
non plus plus tard on les attrape une
forme sévère négative pipi c'est
probablement pour ton domaine de type
ici des questions super c'est la réponse
mais mettons selon toi ou est ce qu on
en est où
au québec par rapport mettront avec
médicale m calmy-rey à ce que c'est
parce que s'adapter à cette maladie le
où ce mode question pour renseigner la
touche je sais pas qu'on en est ici au
québec jusqu'à quel point c
on en parle ou paul surtout planèze
damas pour un sujet qui est sur la table
pour le moment à ma connaissance c'est
fascinant j'ai pris une question le la
mémoire musculaire fait maintenant
quelqu'un qui qui a été un pianiste de
un grand pianiste le dans sa ville qu'il
oblige fait kiki qui était un pianiste
qui s'est joué du piano mais ton blog tu
le mets devant un piano py qui est
capable de jouer sans trop savoir
pourquoi
c'est lié à quoi pourquoi est ce que ce
type de mémoire est capable de rester
mais tombée est-ce que c'est vrai ou si
juste se rebaptiser de cette idée là le
cas puisque quelque chose d'influencé
important dans ta vie plus que ça va
rester dans les autres rappelle péter
capable d'en jouer exact ce soit du
gardien ty le piano c'est bien un
automatisme là pour ceux qui en ont joué
l'on table qui sont des grands virtuoses
poule comme faire du bc qd tu te
réfléchit pas que c'est
bc clt été capable de parler puis
regardez plein de choses en même temps
que tu te rappelles toi que tu as pris
ta cavale de faire du vélo exact donc ça
c'est sceptiques quelques jouets l'on
tape qui est très bon c'est une mémoire
qui vont y rester est très très très
longtemps
ce qui part en premier si la mémoire à
court terme donc tout les événements qui
se passent
récemment ce qui est plus dur au début
donc l'actualité de la honte et lili
signes avant-coureurs donc un truc
collectif légiste ce que je vous ai
nommé là mais après ça aux débutants la
personne commence à être proprement dit
alzheimer c'est il va avoir des
problèmes de mémoire à court terme de se
souvenir des faits de l'actualité ou de
ces personnels qui sont arrivées
récemment
donc si on le voit au début où le tout à
la hauteur dames zara se retrouver dans
des endroits non familles vivent de la
misère à se retrouver dans des endroits
qui sont plus familiers donc une route
qui prenait soin pendant que vous allez
voir sa fille mais le ils soient des
plus compliquées donc si on voit que
c'est une aggravation de 2 cm tableaux
ou des tâches complexes du quotidien d'y
faire ses impôts dont met donc une
personne pourrait raconter ce qui s'est
passé à 1981 mais maintenant exactement
ce qu'est ce qui est ce qui est l'hôte
depuis longtemps surtout des événements
marquants comme et la personne près
souvenir des petits détails très
important de battre pour lui donne
pendant son mariage people est allé
chercher une pinte de lait en avant midi
parce que c'est une zone différente
cerveau c'est les mêmes mais yakassé de
la mémoire à long terme s'est transférée
dans des dents dans le cortex ses gardes
et là puis ça fait parti d'un network
alors que carcasse et de la mémoire à
court terme tout se transforme pas de
court terme à long terme et on intéresse
souvenir que 1
1987 à 13h30 et et les chercheurs ping
délit au départ lancé celia rondelle il
faut que le cerveau face du trident ce
qui est important qu'il ne l'est pas
dans le cas c'est assez important pour
qu'ils s'en souvient de pitié il
engrange dans le cortex parce que c'est
sale une valeur importante pour la
personne qui le rsa pas oublié mais tant
qu'on ne nous autres stars qui veulent
en apprendre plus sur le sujet qui
veulent suivre les recherches qui sont
là tu études et des endroits sur la
toile qu'on peut utiliser pour pour ça
mais pour le moment il ya énormément de
différences y est le site vient en tête
en premier la société alzheimer c'est
sûr vous êtes fait avoir plein de
renseignements super utile sur si vous
vous trouvez que quelqu'un dans votre
âge votre part votre mère si vous pensez
que donc les ressources aller chercher
qui contacter ou farid elle est où sont
les lits clinique de mémoire le puceron
sas et ariza mort mais c'est soit aussi
société alzheimer et maladies
apparentées donc vous allez avoir des
informations sur les médicaments
vous allez pouvoir trouver sur la
démence vasculaire fronto temporale
la cour de louis etc donc vous avez une
bonne boxe une place où commencer après
ça les gens qui vont vous suivre dans le
parcours on peut vous orienter vers les
meilleures places pour pour pour voir
comment tout ça progresse pique nique
qui voit piquant il est quelque chose
qui en tant que scientifique tu dis ça
serait vraiment pertinent que le public
sache c'est par rapport à la main d
abord par rapport à mai mois où
vieillissement ticket qui dit si la
population était plus éduqués là dessus
on pourrait vite et elle te la fermes et
ont eu le dessus
quelque chose qui me vient c'est total
et les mêmes concepts même à atlanta et
si si tu mets une bonne vite fait
attention à ce que tu manges l'activité
pizzas vous c'est gagnant dans tous les
cas qui a l'air facile puisqu'on à dire
non c'est la plus dure au monde où se
libère deux très facile à dire mais très
difficile à faire mais si c'est pour ça
que on en parle encore et tout le monde
sait que l'hypertension c'est pas bon
mais pourquoi il ya un accord qui dit
attention qui ont du diabète qui font
d'obésité tout le monde sait très bien
que c'est pas bon et en surplus pour
tout le monde tout le monde mais on est
dans un patin on est dans nos vies si
c'est difficile de faire les changements
mais tant qu'on veut mais tant qu'on
essaie de dresser la liste le délire des
piles il s'est finalement bien manger
ces souris à l'exit et physique
dormez résumé son stress d'après ce
qu'est ce qu'on dirait quoi maintenant
en fumée pour fumer les contacts
social tac sociaux s'imaginent qu'ils
étaient alcool drogues tout ça aussi
c'est au système un facteur de risque
l'alcool pas trop consommer d'alcool
donc les contacts sociaux on dit ça fait
un bon tour 6 check et ses boxes le
avoir moins de problèmes dans ta vie en
général déjà continue à être actif comme
lorsqu'on vélo là bon parent pixi casse
qui a stimulé intellectuellement pour
poser des questions rester curieux
si les gens qui nous écoutent sont
rendus à avoir fait une heure et demie
de conversation avec nous ils peuvent
choquer la boxe rester actifs
mentalement
aujourd'hui je suis resté en fait ça sur
le tapis roulant jamais j'avais un prof
à l'université laval a pris deux
courants philosophiques et j'ai bougé de
sa musique mais j'ai pris des cours
propyle monsieur thomas de koninck
il y avait les doigts voire 90
maintenant mais il y avait 80 à l'époque
type d'enceintes encore l'université
j'ai jamais vu un érudit comme sous ses
pieds une personne capable de citer t1
infinité de livres de mémoires
il parlait lui lang avait truc dont les
grecs anciens ses fils aient vraiment
puis jean harvey dépôts que je me dise
type arm alstom le avait pris sa
retraite du tabac à 60 ou sépia vais
arrêter de cultiver toujours la
curiosité continue de les y serait s'il
serait sûrement pas aussi intelligent ce
château on les appelle ils espèrent ils
ont essayé il ya cette catégorie de gens
là pour les étudier aussi parce que ce
qu'on ressent fascinante et pourquoi
certaines personnes ont eu leur image et
à tous les ivoiriens qui leur colle puis
il continua aucun ralentissement que
lindsay fleury a maintes fois il peut y
avoir un petit peu mais tu es quand 30 à
50 ans qui était capable de raisonner
comme quelqu'un de 150 ressentant ccc
fortuit donc qu'il ya des trucs qui ont
montré que ces c'est super
et là il y avait un cortex plus et donc
qui diminue ce qui contredit parti nazi
qu'il ya des pertes de matière grise qui
se fait donc ok quand même diminution de
volume puis de la vie voilà la masse de
départ était plus important pic
diminuait moins rapidement que ce qui
était normal pour une idée sur m6 il dit
de réserve cognitive de rester actif de
favoriser les connexions only neurones
puisse essayer
y'a pas mieux parce que ça sa part de
même ce qui courait le mieux avec les
déficits de mémoire c'est lille et les
pertes de connexion entre innovantes
donc si on réussit à conserver nous nos
connexions
on peut prolonger empêcher la
progression de la maladie dans la main
ou même le bilinguisme a été montrée
comme est un protecteur pour la mallette
d'argent parce que ça crie plus de
connexions ton cerveau je suis
exactement donc c'est ce que ça va se
faire dans les zones impliquées dans la
mémoire les paroles comme les de la
douane nicklas de broca donc on peut
comprendre qu'il se passe quelque chose
mais ça va plus loin que ça atteintes
d'autres zones des fonctions exécutif
il a aussi inscrit dans des bus qui sont
importants pour la réflexion de la
planification l'abstraction par les
abstraits donc il aussi ils vont avoir
aussi plus de collection qui vont se
faire
puis ça va hein ça va ralentir la
progression de 4 à 7 ans donc dès qu'on
parle et que l'impact que ça le juste de
ralentir de 2 ans de 6 5 à 20 cents soit
2 des 4 c'est un temps business là mais
oui notre article ce que j'avais lu une
fois c'était justement ils essaient de
trouver des accords il faut revenir aux
mêmes choses mais délesté est et surtout
pas parler que c'était physique puis la
marche put c'étaient les jeunes et je
parlais ce podcast mettez les luttes et
c'est quoi le lait des médias car entre
les gens qui qui qui qui sont
centenaires le tse qui vivent 100 ans et
plus pete est dans tous les cas c'était
des gens qui quotidiennement dans leur
vie pensent depuis longtemps marche
beaucoup noté oui oui
bougez bougez cci par un important même
ma femme a travaillé au musée
armand-frappier puis on a une exposition
qui s'appelle bouger guilly montre à
quel point c'est important de bouger
puis ça s'adresse à tout le monde
puis c'est pas c'est pas le faire est
rendu à 119 entre le gtt des trucs comme
sifflet j ou la maza jamais je me mette
à à pédaler non non c'est des mid life
là un milieu de vie
oui était un choix qui se fait la voix
si je suis pas mal mais le live
il ya une décision à prendre
effectivement la pente descendante puis
tu tires être moins en moins actif et
concevoir la télé elle soit oubliée de
fait rien pour une fois ça fait du bien
dit mais si tu fais juste cela il est un
problème petit vers une panne technique
ou tu dis garde je fais attention à moi
je mets toutes les chances de mon côté
fake je prends des actions concrètes qui
doit l'emmener mon petit bateau le plus
invasive c'est un assez long le imagine
si tu rajoutes deux ans trois ans cinq
ans six ans de dette encore chaud elle
trace ans et l'ont laissé long dans une
vive exact d'hommes seulement
non seulement c'est la durée de la vie
mais c'est là qu'elle fait à quoi bon
rallonger quelque chose qui quand et 1
perte des fonctions complètes m'adapter
mais si c'est pour avoir une bonne
qualité de vie
4 5 10 ans de plus je pense que ça vaut
le coup même cas que l'activité physique
et j'aime pas ce outil sous louait les
légumes j'aime pas si ça vaut la peine
de parler parce que tu vas gagner à la
fin mais le brocoli trouver une façon
d'exprimer c'est vous c'est moi j'ai
trouvé des recettes ouais je me régale
oui je me régale à mardi c'est vrai que
je vais me prononcer geo
merci infiniment
mais c'est une super conversation je
persuadé que tout le monde va voir à des
russes mais vaincu et bien tout coup
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce pas que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et sans
fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe il ya surper tués a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu on les
tourne donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs au monde pictural ou est ce
que on parle d'homme nicole et moi de la
conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets complets abordés ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur une page de turenne les le
lien vers savoir dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte